at least eight people have been killed
in cross border shelling in southern
Lebanon by the Israeli military three
journalists and an 80-year-old woman are
among the Dead from the targeted attack
on the town of teaa the AL mayadin
channel in Beirut has confirmed that its
correspondent far Omar is among the dead
it says a photographer and a local
journalist were also killed in the
attack let's speak to zah hter who's in
the quarter in southern Lebanon for us
and Z can you just give us a bit more
detail about the latest set of clashes
along the border there and are
journalists being deliberately
targeted well this is the third time
journalists have been targeted in
southern Lebanon since the conflict
began seven weeks ago mayad Dean lost
three journalists today on October the
13th Reuters lost lost the journalist
Isam Abdullah uh their position came
Under Fire a few days ago journalists
who were um along the border close to
the Village of yarin they too came under
Fire uh so there there there appears to
be a pattern and journalists are
becoming increasingly concerned that
Israel the Israeli Army wants to silence
them in fact according to the pan Arab
Channel mayad DE the channel That the
two journalists the three journalists
work for um they they are calling this a
deliberate strike and they are saying
that the aim of this is to silence the
media a quote so that it will no longer
uh cover the Israel's brutality not only
in Lebanon but in the West Bank in Gaza
but the the channel went on to say that
it will not be silenced Lebanese
officials have condemned the what they
are calling an aggression they've
they've told the Lebanese Army to launch
an investigation reporters Without
Borders uh investigated the attack on
October the 13th and um it found that
the journalists were not collateral
damage in the shooting and that they
were deliberately targeted so it's
becoming very difficult for journalists
to operate along the border I can tell
you you know even wearing the our Gear
with our camera is just not enough to
keep you safe and there are many roads
empty roads empty Villages you drive
through them in the back of your mind
you think that you're going to be
targeted by an Israel drone um so
journalists really are not
protected okay thank you uh so much Z
there Z for us in southern Lebanon D kab
is a columnist at Al monor and a former
board member of the international press
Institute he says there is a concerted
effort by Israel to Target journalists
and that Global media networks need to
reaffirm that journalism is not a
crime Lebanon is not the only place we
saw
sh American Palestinian was killed
without anybody being held accountable
we've had 50 journalists in Gaza and
media workers killed 60 media Outlets
that were destroyed in Gaza no one is
holding Israel accountable and un
unfortunately uh the the people that are
V victims are the ones who are supposed
to be telling us what's happening Israel
thinks that by killing journalists they
can keep information away in today's
modern age anybody with a phone can can
tell us what's happening but they're
taking away the professional journalist
whose job it is to tell us what is
happening on the battlefield and it's
really a it's a crime and it's really a
shame that a country that claims to be
some kind of a democracy is is killing
journalists killing civilians and
getting away with it International press
Institute which I'm a member of and I
was a member of the board the committed
to protect journalist reported to that B
all issue statements but doesn't seem to
care I it's uh it's really amazing that
our fellow journalists in major media
Outlets are also not giving enough
attention to what is happening to
members of their own uh media Outlet and
their own colleagues in the profession
so uh we need the institutes to speak
but we also need the major journalists
from major outsets CNN ABC CBS all of
them should follow the suit of these
institutes and say don't touch
journalists journalism is not a crime
the crime is killing the journalist and
Israel is committing this war crime and
must be told to stop